[Music]
welcome to Koch news this time we're
talking about Taylor Swift's part in
Deadpool 3 New Impressions from The
Joker Sequel and a new Friday the 13th
movie by blumhouse we also have
information on the Bambi live action
movie a remake of the office and price
changes on Netflix so grab your popcorn
because here are the
details after Halloween and The Exorcist
blumhouse now wants to revive the next
horror series Jason Vorhees is to cause
fear and Terror again in a new Friday
the 13th film the production company
blumhouse Productions is considered a
constant in the horror genre and
regularly records great success through
several Productions films like
Paranormal Activity Sinister or get out
should definitely be a well-known name
for DieHard horror fans the sequels to
Halloween staged by director David
Gordon green were also very successful
now in addition to the remake of The
Exorcist another iconic horror series
will be Resurrected we're talking about
Friday the 13th in an interview with
inverse blumhouse producer Ryan Turk
revealed that more films centered around
masked serial killer Jason bores are
firmly marked on the studio schedule he
said they plan to go back to the classic
formula of previous films according to
turk it doesn't take many ingredients to
create a Friday the 13th movie A Summer
Camp the campers and Jason Vorhees with
a mask in addition to Blum House's
planned films a series titled Crystal
Lake will also be released within the
franchise which the hit studio a24 in a
collaboration with peacock will be
responsible for among the actors in the
series will be Adrien King who already
appeared in the first two films in 1980
and 1981 a real veteran of the series
splatter movie fans should hopefully get
their money's worth news from The Joker
the hit from 2019 brought lead actor Wen
Phoenix to the Academy Award for best
actor in a leading role in the upcoming
year he repeatedly gets the chance to
show his talent in Joker 2 fully ado a
new photo of the sequel is likely to
further increase the anticipation on
October 3rd just in time exactly 1 year
before the movie's released dat
cameraman Lawrence Sher published a new
picture on his Instagram Channel which
presents us Phoenix in his iconic role
on the picture we see Arthur Fleck
standing in the rain surrounded by
colorful umbrellas this particular scene
might remind us a little bit of Jean
Kelly's classical musical Singing in the
Rain possibly a reference to the film
after all the sequel is said to contain
some music passages how many of them
will be presented to us in Joker 2 fly
ad do remains to be seen Hilder gonad
here who also contributed to the music
of the first film will once again be
responsible for the soundtrack of part
two certainly the casting of the second
lead role helped to let music play in
even bigger part than it already had in
the first movie Harley Quinn is
portrayed by Lady Gaga who will
unquestionably show her musical Talent
as she did in 2018s A Star is Born a
film that won the Oscar for the best
song Joker 2 will be be released in
cinemas on October 4th
2024 update for Bambi alongside Snow
White Hercules and Lilo and Stitch the
famous Bambi will also receive a
liveaction film adaptation however some
changes to the original content will be
made the animated classic Bambi is
already considered one of the most
beautiful and simultaneously saddest
Disney films of all time and has left
its mark on generations of people so
it's not a surprise that Disney would
now like to see the material realized in
the form of a liveaction film in this
way a new and potentially younger
audience should be captivated the story
of Bambi will apparently be told in a
more contemporary way in order to not
confront the audience with a topic of
depth too much according to co-writer
Lindsay Anderson beer in an interview
with collider she does not want to spoil
the plot but with regard to the death of
a mother some children and parents are
more sensitive nowadays than they were
in the past she thinks it would be
useful to the original to shape the
story so that children could relate to
it more nowadays what this new reboot
will look like in detail remains to be
seen besides since the film is in an
early stage of development it's most
likely that some time will elapse before
we get any concrete information on the
story and a potential cast we will keep
you
posted the fans are going crazy for
quite some time now rumors have been
circulating that Taylor Swift might be a
part of Deadpool 3 a video has appeared
on the net now which is likely to cause
speculations once again the video
published by Diana Rini shows Superstar
Taylor Swift watching the game between
the Kansas Chiefs and the New York Jets
something the Press was just waiting for
however the video might also be
interesting for movie fans because Swift
is accompanied by those responsible for
Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman
and director Shawn Levy the three have
of course been spotted together many
times the company of Taylor Swift
however is special and could further
fuel the rumors about her possible
appearance in the popular superhero
movie According to some fans Swift could
take on the role of dazzler a mutant who
already played a small role in Simon
kimber's X-Men dark Phoenix where she
was portrayed by hon Sage dazzler is one
of Marvel's most powerful superheroin
and has the ability to convert any kind
of sound into rays of light in addition
she is an extremely talented singer and
is also very skilled in close combat
currently it is assumed that Swift's
possible appearance will only be a cameo
for the moment however rumors have been
circulating for some time that Kevin
feige is playing with the idea of making
Swift part of the MCU after all the
singer has already convinced the
audience in several film roles and is
considered a versatile Talent anyhow an
official confirmation of the rumors is
still missing but at least something
seems to be happening behind the scenes
on the other hand in front of the scenes
there is unfortunately still a break in
production due to the actor strike we
hope that the film shooting can't
continue as soon as possible and we'll
let you know once something
happens news from the office the US
version of the office has undoubtedly
made history and is still considered one
of the most popular series among comedy
fans now a reboot is supposed to follow
which will be directed by the same
showrunner once again for over 8 years
the hit series The Office provided great
entertainment the show starring Steve
Carell helped with the Breakthrough of
some actors for example John krinski who
celebrated further success with a quiet
place or Jack Ryan but the TV show was
also popular with the critics and
managed to win five Emmys the concept of
the story originated in Great Britain
and was invented by comedian and Ricky
Jas the successful format was then
successfully adapted in several other
countries since the ninth season of the
office has reached the ripe old age of
10 years in the meantime Hollywood
apparently thinks about a new addition
for which a well-known person has
already been confirmed Greg Daniels will
return once again and be responsible for
the project Daniels already worked as a
showrunner and screenwriter on the
original and also directed 13 episodes
of the show although the office veteran
has repeatedly expressed pessimism about
a reboot in the past he nevertheless
revealed how he would approach the the
project in his opinion the reboot should
be set in the same world as the original
but focus on different characters
nevertheless it's not impossible that we
would see some familiar faces at least
as a guest appearance this news should
be greeted with enthusiasm by many fans
because at least some former actors such
as John krinski and Mindy Kaling have
already expressed a positive opinion
towards a return Screen Rant said
whether Steve Carell will also return as
his iconic character remains uncertain
if the reboot is successful other
countries could follow the example what
do you think would Steve Carell come
back and will the office even work
without him in a leading role share your
opinions and ideas in the
comments Netflix is Raising its prices a
few months ago the streaming service
took action against account sharing and
now there's a rumor of another price
increase to follow up Netflix is still
considered an authority amongst
streaming services but it also had to
face all kinds of criticism in recent
months many users criticized not only
the quality of Netflix's own products
but also the prohibition of account
sharing and the increase in prices as
the Wall Street Journal reported the
company is currently thinking about an
increase in several markets again which
it could justify with the ongoing strike
of actors and writers tech radar also
suspects that Netflix has been planning
to make prices spiral upwards for quite
some time whether Netflix users will
simply accept another increase in their
subscriptions remains to be seen however
it is clear that the streaming giant is
standing in an unflattering light at the
moment if you still need spooky film
record recommendations for Halloween
we've put together the best and scariest
horror movies in a video for you if
you're more into action movies you might
like to check out the first trailer of
The Beekeeper with Jason Statham we hope
that you enjoyed this week's video and
be sure to check us out next week for
more Koch Che News until then take
[Music]
care